the biggest fight
or should i say negotiation
my wife and i have ever had was over
toothpaste you see my wife is
a roller and i'm a squeezer and nothing
upsets a roller more than a squeezer
to this day after 20 years of marriage
we still have two tubes of toothpaste
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast negotiation plays an important
role in our daily lives you might be
striving to get an increase in your
salary support for a project less screen
time for your kids or more quality time
with your romantic partner becoming a
better negotiator can help you and the
people you interact with today i am so
excited to be joined by maggie neal the
adams distinguished professor of
management emerita at the gsb
additionally along with thomas lease
maggie is the co-author of the book
getting more of what you want her
research focuses on negotiation and team
performance
welcome maggie thanks so much for being
here thanks matt it's a pleasure yep you
are well known for your keen insights
your engaging teaching style and
humorous storytelling and along with
your love of horses
so excited to have you here i'd like to
get started i know you have a particular
way of looking at negotiation how do you
define negotiation and what do you see
as the definition of a successful
negotiation well too many of us approach
a negotiation as a battle
and that battle is characterized by i'm
going to try to get stuff from you and
i'm going to try to keep you from
getting my stuff
and if that's how you think about
negotiation you're already in uphill
climb
because what that perspective does is it
frames how you interact and evaluate
your counterpart and yourself
you're going to evaluate your
counterpart through that screen of
battle
and so what i suggest is rather than
thinking about your counterpart as your
enemy think about negotiation
as collaborative problem solving
collaborative problem solving has three
dimensions the first is that i
as the protagonist negotiator and better
off
better off than my alternatives better
off than my status quo better often had
i not negotiated
now that may sound like a low bar
because what reasonable person is going
to negotiate to be worse off that's true
except we all have you know each of us
have been in negotiations multiple times
probably where we knew at the moment the
second before we said yes we should walk
away
but we said yes anyway because we
privileged agreement
over the quality of deal
so that's number one is i as the
protagonist need to be made better off
but number two
there's no command and control in
negotiation i cannot force you to say
yes
all that i can do
is present proposals to you
where you think it's in your interest to
say yes and we agree on a common course
of action so that means i need to
understand who you are what your
interests are your preferences your
motivations what your challenges are
and i need to be able to answer the
question why would you say yes to my
proposal
because if i don't have the answer to
that question i'm not ready to negotiate
so the second part is really about
reconnaissance and reflection into who
you're negotiating with
absolutely
and the third point is
that when i present a proposal to you
i'm going to present that proposal as a
solution to a problem that you have
ah
and that's the crux of the collaborative
problem-solving perspective what it does
is it takes this out of me against you
i like that a lot that that reinforces
several things that we've heard across
many of these podcast episodes is you
really have to know your audience who
you're talking to and you have to frame
your communication in a way that helps
and supports them it's not just about
you so i i love that you're echoing that
yes and and the not just about you is
the whole point
what suggestions you have to help us
better plan for our negotiations are
there things we can do to prepare
ourselves and those we negotiate with
absolutely so i need to understand my
situation
the first thing i need to understand is
what are my alternatives
what happens to me in the case of an
impasse
there have been a ton of research in
this area and it's really very clear
those folks with better alternatives on
average walk away with more in the
negotiation
and the reason they do that is because
they're more willing to walk away
so let's say i have a really good
alternative
it makes it easier for me to walk away
so if you want an outcome a negotiated
outcome
with me
you've got to actually pay me
to stay and engage with you
but my alternatives are outside the
negotiation but they have a huge impact
on how i behave because they affect the
second parameter which is my reservation
price
my reservation price it's the tipping
point in a negotiation
and it is arguably the most strategic
piece of information because it tells me
where that point is
where i am willing to walk away in fact
if i am negotiating it and i am at my
reservation price i should be so
indifferent
as to the outcome that i can flip a coin
and if it lands heads i walk away
and if it lands tails i say yes
and i would argue most of us don't ever
think about
you know most people don't and even
people who do
often times don't have the discipline
to be able to honor that reservation
price because they value
getting a yes
over the quality of the deal
and this is what's so critical because
if you don't have a reservation in price
you don't have a point your bottom line
if you're not clear what your bottom
line is and you don't have the
discipline to maintain that bottom line
then whatever surplus exists in the
negotiation can easily flow to your
counterpart
because it really is that point where
you say no
i won't do this right but you need to
know where that is
and now if all you focused on were those
two aspects
your bottom line
are what happens if you got an impasse
then what's going to happen is
you're going to systematically
underperform in your negotiation and you
do so
because of a very powerful psychological
process
expectations drive our behavior
so if my expectations about what i can
get in this negotiation
are centered on my bottom line
are what happens to me if i get an
impasse
if that's where my mind is that's where
i will end up
so i must
leverage up my expectations
i must think about an aspiration
an aspiration is
an assessment and that that doesn't mean
i look at them and say oh things went
really well the perfect world i would
get all of this no what i say is here's
my situation
here's my skills and ability here's my
counterpart here's their situation if
everything went in my direction
in this situation
optimistically what could i hope to
achieve
that doesn't say my counterpart
completely you know sort of rolls over
on their back and he says i give no
they're going to be trying to get more
of what they want
but if things go my way what could i
hope to achieve
and what i've found matt is that folks
rarely
rarely identify
an aspiration
sometimes they will identify a
reservation price absolutely sometimes
their alternatives yes
but they rarely use what i think is
really one of the secret ingredients in
successful negotiation which is setting
an aspiration
and having a focus
from your perspective on that aspiration
previously on this podcast we've talked
a fair bit about how to structure our
messages are there specific best
practices for how you structure
negotiation messages for example i know
you've done some research on chunking
and i find it really compelling can you
tell us a bit about that
well there's two there's ways to think
about chunking so number one is that too
often in negotiation we we tell
ourselves that the correct way to
negotiate is uh one issue at a time
and that strategy
is a recipe for value destruction and
negotiation and so part of what
we want to do is we want to be able to
negotiate
multiple issues
simultaneously
and the reason we want to do that is
because not every issue is equally
important to both of us
and so what i want to do is i want to
get a sense of value or importance of
the issues over which we could negotiate
how important are they to you compared
to how important they are to me i'm
quite willing to concede
on an issue that's important to you
especially if it's not that important to
me in order to get
a concession on an issue that's
important to me
that's the beginning of the chunking
process so where are the asymmetries in
our preferences
and then what i want to do is i want to
negotiate at the package level so think
about as you make a proposal all the
issues and kind of try to work with them
all simultaneously i want to craft a
proposal that reflects
our unique contributions as opposed to i
want to win that issue you on the last
issue
i see so in essence chunking gives you
multiple levers to pull that that you
don't have if you're going issue by
issue
so often when we negotiate we bring
emotion to the party we're frustrated
we're nervous we're excited what role
does emotion play in negotiation and do
you have any guidance on how to handle
our emotions in the heat of a
negotiation
there's been a fair amount of research
on
the emotional
aspect of negotiation so the first thing
i would like to say which is sort of
counterintuitive is that emotions affect
how we think and the different types of
emotions affect how systematic our
thinking is
and so there's a fair amount of research
that looks at the looks at uh what
emotions encourage
deep thinking versus encourage top of
the mind think
and it turns out that it's not about
happy or angry right it turns out that
actually happy and angry
both create
an emphasis on top of the mind thinking
you want to sort of think about the
emotions that actually get your
counterpart
to think deeply and those are things
like surprise
or sadness those are emotions that
actually
are associated with much more deep
information processing
thank you for that information uh we
have a tradition on this podcast uh
before we end i'd like to ask everybody
the same three questions okay question
number one if you were to capture the
best communication advice you have ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would that
be
i'd say insight
often arrives from unlikely sources ah
i like that sounds like you've got some
history with that uh advice
any anything you're willing to share
well part of the issue and and you know
let me give a little pitch here i have
um a tedx talk from stanford about
negotiating with my horse
one of my most fails negotiations was
with my horse and she also taught me a
whole lot about negotiation subsequent
to that insight comes from really
interesting places
yes i'm impressed that we went so long
without talking about horses so i'm glad
it came up uh question number two who is
a communicator i guess i will say a
human communicator that you admire and
why
so i'm gonna give you two because one of
them is historic and one of them is
current then tony fauci has is an
amazing communicator and has to manage
such a tight rope communicate to
multiple and competing audiences
simultaneously i am just in awe of his
ability that's number one and i actually
had the opportunity to work with him
years and years ago when he was
presenting some of his hiv research at a
conference and he is as authentic and
genuine as you see him today he was back
then he is who he is and i think that's
part of what makes him successful who is
your historical
reference
john kennedy
and the reason is because john kennedy
moved an entire generation to do stuff
they never thought they were going to do
and and it even goes back to his
inaugural speech
you know ask not what your country can
do for you but what you can do for your
country
um many folks answered that call and did
and began doing things like the peace
corps
um and did you know went out to
basically change the world because that
was what he asked us to do
so number three what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe
first one is concern for the other
if i'm trying to communicate to somebody
i need to understand where they are
and i need to frame my communication in
a way that meets them where they are and
then i need to sort of
help figure out how
that communication can move them to a
place that i would prefer them to be
and so that's why i think for example
negotiation is such an important skill
maybe together we can come up with a
better solution than either one of us
could have imagined separately
what a great recipe that would make
maggie thank you so much your insights
into negotiation will help all of us do
a better job of getting what we want and
fostering more collaborative
relationships i really appreciate your
time
thanks so much matt it was great talking
to you
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by stanford university's
graduate school of business
for more information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
or subscribe to our show wherever you
get your podcasts